well it's a way of representing really
large numbers and really small numbers
in a compact way
so what we do is we want to write the
number as a power of 10 and this is you
know considered an order of magnitude so
if you're comparing scientific numbers
and one is 10 to the 2nd power versus 10
to the third power you're going to know
that the one that's 10 to the third
power is going to be a larger number by
an order of magnitude of 1 but here what
you can see is when we write this
scientific notation number you want a
single digit of K besides zero in front
of the decimal point okay to the left of
the decimal point and the other
significant digits to the right of the
decimal point so let's take a look at
some examples and I'll show you what I
mean so here we have thousands millions
billions so this is 3 billion 120
million it's a really large number we
want to convert it into the scientific
notation form so right now the decimal
point is right here at the end even if
it's not written it's understood to be
there and we're going to move it 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 places so this is going to be
3 point 1 2 times 10 to the 9th power
now you can see I dropped all of these
zeros here ok these are not significant
digits and I have this as 10 to the 9th
power which means it's like multiplying
three point one two times 10 times 10
times 10 times 10 9 9 times every time
you multiply by 10 it moves that decimal
point one place to the right making this
larger and larger until you get back to
the original number three billion 120
million and the next problem here we
have a really small number this is the
tenths hundredths thousandths
ten-thousandths hundred-thousandths
millionths ten millionths of 100
millions billions this is 182 billion
which is a really small number so again
what we're going to do is we want this
decimal point to end up right here so
that we just have a single bit non-zero
digit in front of the decimal point and
other significant digits to the right of
the decimal point so we're going to move
this decimal one two three four five six
seven places this is going to be one
point e two times ten to the okay you
ready negative seven so what the
negative seven means is that when you
see this number you're going to move
this decimal seven places to the left if
you've watched some of my other videos
working with exponents a negative
exponent this is really like one over
ten to the seventh power and this is
really like dividing 1.82 by ten by ten
by ten seven times every time you divide
it by ten it makes it smaller by
removing that decimal one place to the
left until you get back to the original
number so when you see a negative
exponent a negative power of 10
that'll indicate to you that this is a
really small number when you see that
positive exponent okay for the power of
10 you know this is a really large
number let's take a look at some other
examples here we have another very large
number the decimal points right here
what we can do to make it a little bit
quicker is wherever you see a comma that
represents three places so we're gonna
move it 3 6 9 12 so this is going to be
five point zero zero one we need these
zeros these are placeholders okay these
are important and one is a significant
digit but we don't need these remaining
zeros so this is times 10 to the 3 6 9
12 10 to the 12th okay so if you see
this number 10 to the 12th all you have
to do is move it 12 places to the right
and you're back to the standard number
the decimal form so here we've got
another really small number where do we
want that decimal point to end up here
here here here well we want to move it
enough places so that there's just one
digit a single digit non-zero digit in
front of the decimal point to the left
of the decimal point so you can see
that's one two three four five there we
go so one point zero zero seven five
these are significant digits these are
placeholders of
we don't need these zeros one point zero
zero seven five times ten to the
negative right one two three four five
negative fifth power okay so that's how
to convert from a standard notation to
scientific notation now let's go the
other direction here we have a
scientific number what is the ten to the
fourth to tell us that this is a really
large number we want to move this
decimal point right here four places to
the right
so that's going to be three now going to
move it one two three four and there's
the placeholders the zeros so this is
30,000 this one here you can see the
negative seven this tells us this is a
really small number we want to move that
decimal point seven places to the left
so let's do that so five point zero zero
eight I'm going to move it one in front
of the five two three four five six
seven okay there's a new location of the
decimal point and these are placeholders
okay so you can see it's point zero zero
zero zero zero zero five zero zero eight
okay this one here 10 to the six we know
it's a really large number and again
this 10 to the six tells us we're going
to move that decimal point six places to
the right so this is going to be three
one two
that's one two three four five six and
we put our zeros in and there's our new
location of our decimal point
okay last example what do we do here
we've got a negative exponent that tells
us to move the decimal point to the left
this is a really small number so we're
going to move it five places to the left
I'll just do it right here one two three
four five and we have our placeholders
our zeros so this is point zero zero
zero zero four one one okay so this has
been a video about how to work with
numbers in scientific notation and
converting them from standard notation
the scientific notation and vice versa
I'll see you in the next video